une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le podcasts
[Musique]
grand plaisir aujourd'hui de recevoir
quelqu'un qui est important dans le
paysage musical québécois il s'agit de
lougens
[Musique]
ses vieux boys de carquois 12 ans plus
tard de 12 13 ans plus fort même après
leur dernier album il y avait annoncé en
fait que le groupe se dissociait bien
sûr sa galère solo comme comme vous avez
constaté et puis là c'est le retour du
groupe avec un nouvel album l'album va
être sorti au moment que que ce podcast
toujours un ben de qui est à
l'avant-garde qui qui
qui donne quelque chose de de vraiment
spécial je dois vraiment content moi
c'est un groupe que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup écouté dans le temps de volume
du vent puis de verre 2008-2010 je
trempé là-dessus vraiment beaucoup j'ai
suivi la carrière de l'ugeance c'est une
inspiration pour moi j'ose le dire que
c'est quelqu'un que je respecte beaucoup
qui est extrêmement talentueux
extrêmement inspirant puis ça a été
vraiment une belle conversation en fait
on est allé dans les zones que je
n'aurais pas
mais c'est pas entendu en fait on a
parlé
[Musique]
une grosse démarche de recherche
spirituelle dans les dernières années
puis ça transparaît dans un son attitude
et ça ça prestance et sa présence mais
ensuite je te mentir je pense que on est
vraiment dans la saison de de
spiritualité de croissance personnelle
de recherche de soi on aussi parler
évidemment de musique de carquois dans
leur processus créatif de sa carrière en
général comment que
son premier album le 13e étage comment
que sa vie a changé comment que ça a été
la gloire instantanée ou presque
très très content d'avoir rencontré ce
gars à personne d'avoir pu avoir une
conversation avec mais je trouve très
choyé vraiment les grandes artères ça a
été un album extrêmement important pour
moi dans mon
cheminement en tant qu'individu fait que
c'est un honneur de le recevoir puis
c'est tout le temps le fun des podcasts
parce que
surprendre par la conversation puis la
conversation qui nous amène à des
endroits comme tu disais inattendus puis
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé puis
c'est le fun de juste se laisser aller
laisser porter par ces conversations là
quand ça arrive fait que on espère que
vous allez vous laisser porter autant
que nous
podcast est présenté par la formation
vidéo Creator Pro qui est en fait une
formation en ligne sur le comment créer
des belles vidéos avec une valeur
ajoutée à un air ou est-ce que les
vidéos sont extrêmement importants le
contenu c'est la clé la formation était
mis en place par Henri et Niri de la
compagnie hxn qui est une compagnie de
production audiovisuelle avec qui nous
on a fait à faire déjà et donc les gars
ils connaissent leur affaire puis donc
ils ont travaillé aussi avec pas juste
le studio SF en termes de grosses
compagnie avec qui donc
les boîtiers avec wati cosmétiques
aussi
bref ils font ça professionnelnement
dans la vie c'est des maîtres de l'or de
la vidéo autant de de capturer les
images que du montage puis dans la vidéo
de 45 minutes qui est gratuite ils vont
vous donner toutes leurs astuces pour
être passé à l'autre niveau pour payer
une coupe de coche comme on dit dans vos
skills de vidéos puis ça peut être ça
peut être juste parce que vous voulez
faire des TikTok pour le fun ou des Bill
sur Instagram ou pour votre job vous
avez besoin d'avoir une base en vidéo ou
pour peu importe votre compagnie c'est
ça des fois quand vous lancez ma part on
porte plusieurs chapeaux je sais c'est
mon cas puis moi je suis mon prof idéal
puis j'ai clairement besoin d'une
meilleure formation si vous voulez plus
d'informations sur cette formation là ça
fait beaucoup de formations quand tu dis
le mot information aussi l'information
sur la formation si vous voulez de
l'information sur la formation le lien
est dans la description du podcast puis
merci aux deux Boys et à leur formation
de croire au podcast et merci à vous de
croire au Boys et d'aller suivre leur
cours en ligne 45 minutes gratuitement
10 astuces pour créer le meilleur vidéo
c'est l'heure de parler de matscape
avez-vous des bons
de produits pour homme qui font toutes
sortes de produits pour le soin de
votre pilosité ou votre hygiène
personnelle
juste pour être bien dans le fond on
vous parle aujourd'hui du autre smooth
package ce que c'est un petit
rasoir un rasoir est ma foi très agile
et très précis et vraiment qui qui conçu
en fait principalement pour la région
des bijoux de famille comme on pourrait
dire poliment
on commence la publicité en disant
pour les raisons de famille qu'on
pourrait dire puis dans ce cas-là il y a
d'autres choses
il y a le gel pour raser sans irriter
évidemment vous savez que cette région
là irritée ceux qui en ont une région de
même ok c'est poche c'est très
littéralement poche quand la poche est
irritée c'est poche puis ensuite on a un
exfoliator pour
assurer d'éliminer les poils incarnés
puis parce que ça aussi un poil incarné
sur le sachet
ça ça c'est tout ça vient dans le
transport de package si vous voulez vous
le procurer ou procurer n'importe quel
autre produit de nos préférés chez
menscape vous pouvez utiliser code promo
sans filtre pour 20% de rabais livraison
gratuite puis c'est tout ce que vous
allez avoir besoin pour l'entretien sous
la ceinture merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci beaucoup de prendre du temps pour
nous voir lâcher que ton horaire
aujourd'hui puis hier c'est du stock
quand même
oui c'est ça puis en plus c'est ça qui
est drôle c'est que je pense que vous
êtes officiellement la dernière chose
à l'horaire du calendrier de Louis Jean
Cormier c'est parce que j'ai encore mis
vient de se mettre dans un garde-robe de
cercle sur la bouche sport avec une
cellophane dessus
carquois c'est que j'ai j'ai mis j'ai
mis tout côté je voulais vraiment pas
mélanger les affaires c'est vraiment le
fun ça me donne
ça me permet de respirer le style le
retour à un bandes ça fait ça fait comme
si les épaules relâchent un peu la la de
rien la carrière
tu décides de tout
mais
c'est quand même 5 personnes qui se
tiennent ensemble qui te met un projet à
bout de brosser vraiment plus relaxe
mais c'est drôle quand même que tu vois
ça comme ça vraiment comme
deux entités séparées si je sais pas à
quel point je vais réussir à le faire
comme il faut là mais c'est c'est prévu
comme ça dans le booking puis dans la
plonger le management la gérance de
carrière puis je me verrai Malte comme
lui j'étais censé faire les Gémeaux le
gala des jumeaux dans deux semaines
j'étais censé faire un petit une tonne
avec Ariane royale j'avais dit oui juste
pour ça parce que j'aime beaucoup Ariane
puis finalement le booking a changé rien
ne pouvait plus le lion changer de nom
etc puis je faisais quoi je suis
vraiment dans quoi là je viens de
commencer et puis ça par rapport que
Louis-Jean Cormier se retrouve à TV en
ce moment c'est pour ça
ordre du contraire
dans le sens où premièrement la carrière
de kerquois n'existe comme pas vraiment
ça veut dire qu'on est plus dans une
démarche de plantes carrière de
développement de carrière puis de fait
qu'on on est plus comme au jour le jour
on a réservé évidemment du temps on
n'est pas quand même
dire on est des citoyens du monde
mais
c'est pas tous des cons c'est vraiment
cool en fait on représente c'est juste
que là si on veut être proactif puis
aussi permettre à tous ces chacun de
pouvoir continuer à faire ses affaires
je viens sa gauche sa carrière moi j'ai
la mienne chez toi mais on peut pas dire
non plus ok mais on repart pour une
période indéterminée c'est que on a
arrêté des dates mais effectivement
c'est peut-être quand même plus une
période indéterminée qui d'autre chose
parce que long là on a envie de partir
sur la tournée on a du plaisir on se
retrouve active je pense que personne en
ce moment out au dernier jour
ça fait qu'on est pas on n'est pas du
tout dans le même mode que quand on
avait terminé la la tournée des chemins
de verte ça veut dire qu'on a décidé
qu'on arrêterait après
on a décidé qu'on arrêterait avant de
commencer la tournée puis on savait que
le dernier chose c'était vraiment
officiellement le dernier show donc on a
eu un an et demi à finir ça va finir
c'est vraiment pas le cas en ce moment
c'est tout à fait puis c'est dessus
comme si rien n'était ne s'était arrêté
quelque part on pourrait dire Oui puis
quelque part on dirait que c'est
vraiment mieux c'est dans le sens où
c'est mieux que syrienne n'était arrêté
parce que on a pris une bonne décennie
pour faire d'autres choses pas d'autres
projets mon avis a complètement changé
ma vie personnelle ma vie
professionnelle c'est la même chose pour
chacun des membres du ban de quand tu te
retrouves 10 ans après je dis c'est
impossible que ça soit la même chose
c'est mieux tu sais c'est du vin qui est
vieilli les tanins ont fondu mais ouais
on était tous à quelque part meilleur
c'est pour la d'albums et puis pour la
tournée pour le spectacle toutes ces
c'est comme mais à quelque part rien ne
change dans le sens où le la symbiose
des cinq garçons est toujours la même
puis c'est vraiment le fun de jouer
ensemble puis ces personnes a perdu
de quoi que ce soit là
ça va et ben puis comment que comment
qu'il l'idée d'un potentiel de retour
est né le thé ça fait si longtemps que
ça se germe est-ce que c'est je sais que
ça fait des shows ponctuel c'est ici et
là est-ce que c'est là que ça fait hey
il me semble
qu'il y a eu au départ là on avait
vraiment mis la clé un peu d'emporte en
disant ou c'est pas là
mais c'est on voyait pas très bien là un
avenir tes a pris comme mettons 4 4 5
ans avant que là on commence à juillet
ça goûte jouait de son bar c'est ça
l'effet de 4 albums sur l'eau il y avait
Martin la montagne de bassiste comme
comme Baptiste pendant un petit court
moment au début
moi je continuais à côtoyer François
Lafontaine pas mal en même temps on se
voyait moins il était dans Galaxy il
était dans le projet de sa blonde
Marie-Pierre
[Musique]
je me rappelle ma Nicki j'avais le goût
de voir mais moi j'étais rendu dans une
autre zone aussi mais ça a été très
rapide mon affaire quand j'ai décidé de
faire le 13e étage on avait à peine fini
la tournée de kerquois puis je t'ai
comme bon mais je vais essayer en
parallèle pour voir je voyais vraiment
le truc genre marque des rives versus
Zébulon
ça m'était pas fin quoi que ce soit puis
ça a été impressionnant la fulgurance à
laquelle ça c'est que en fait que ça
explose le projet sur le je m'attendais
pas assez je m'attendais vraiment pas à
ce que il y a eu autant de succès puis
que les gens me suivent avec autant
d'ardeurs je me disais ils vont ils vont
peut-être être juste m'écrire ces chiens
Picard quoi c'est toi qui a quitté le
bain de ces hommes c'est toi qui a pris
c'était pas moi ça c'est la pure vérité
il y avait un des membres qui était
vraiment fatigué puis il était comme un
petit dépression puis c'est lui qui a
diamond moi si je continue je pète aux
fraises
continuer ça à moi il y avait dit puis
je fais non non non il y a personne en
fait c'est vraiment un ban de 5 c'est 5
individus là sont pas du tout
interchangeables
un chemin assez je pense aussi ça tout
le travail de jus de bras qu'on a donné
avec carquois dans les 15 années qu'on a
été en activité au début ont été
vraiment bénéfiques pour tout le monde
et pour beaucoup pour ma carrière seul
aussi à quelque part parce que le
travail avait été fait surtout le moment
où on a décidé de se retirer
un moment où je pensais peut-être un
moment où ça allait le mieux
drôle de mouvement c'est une bonne idée
tu es dans le sens où c'est la recette
parfaite pour créer une espèce de
ça sonne prétentieux mais c'est pas du
tout ça que je veux dire mais c'est une
espèce de mythe de zone de métaux les
gens comme yaraissent surtout ceux qui
auraient aimé voir garde quoi bien c'est
fini ça reste un superbe
journaliste hier avec les gars que ça
gonfle c'est une belle ballonne mais le
mot dès que tu décides de faire un
retour tu pètes la valeur
énorme ça va être cool mais tu peux pas
la regonfler
ton pétales
ça m'avait fait ça à moi avec moi
après trois albums c'était genre les
trois albums le son absolument débiles
les autres tout le monde va faire sa
propre affaire puis effectivement qu'il
y a un espèce d'aspect mythique éclaté
quand ils sont revenus mais c'était
jusqu'au dire voir après mais c'est
l'effet si c'est que le Cobain n'avait
continuer de faire des albums
jusqu'à aujourd'hui peut-être que ça
serait
quand même changer l'histoire de la
musique mais c'est l'aspect qui est
quelque chose qui est arrêté dans le
temps puis on a on n'aura jamais vu
qu'est-ce qui aurait fait après ça crée
quand même les Beatles
bon encore
à l'échelle du Québec derrière les
années j'ai eu la chance de travailler
avec Serge Fiori de harmonium sur un
projet de cirque pitié on a aussi lié
d'amitié c'est devenu vraiment très fort
puis c'est par le biais de Serge que
j'ai compris cette affaire là beaucoup
la la
gestion entre guillemets du mythe puis
de digestion parce que tu peux quand
même un peu jouer avec dans le sens où à
petit échelle mais mon ami Martin Léon
était un gars qui travaille comme ça
beaucoup ça se fait un album quasiment
au 10 ans puis il me disait souvent
c'est les gens faut que tu apprennes
aussi à te laisser désirer donne le
temps aux gens de s'ennuyer puis lui
effectivement quand il décide de faire
une tournée ces soldats de partout dans
les saletés moyennes parce que les gens
comme enfin il retourne
à tous les deux semaines à Victoriaville
les gens vont commencer ça devient plus
un événement soit
mais juste là en parler de ballon dans
tout l'impression que la baloune
carquois est encore plus grosse qu'au
moment où vous avez arrêté moi j'ai
comme les filles
c'est ce que moi j'appelle le mythe
c'est que ce qu'il y a comme un travail
qui se fait de fermentation pendant
le repos aussi puis
ce qui est drôle avec carquois et
j'arrive pas encore à me l'expliquer
tant que ça c'est que là on a on assiste
à une vague de nouveaux fans de 20 ans
de notre âge mais le mot je suis le
premier du ban d'avoir eu des enfants
puis je les ai eu tôt quand même puis ma
fille a juste 16 ans et je me dis ok
comme probablement qu'on rejoignait
aussi beaucoup de gens de 50 ans qui ont
eu des enfants qui ont été qui ont
partagé leur moi qui ont partagé mais je
pense que le mythe accélère aussi ce
phénomène là qui est le plus beau
phénomène tant que moi au niveau de la
du rayonnement de la musique c'est le
bouche à oreille puis on a tendance à
l'oublier parce qu'on met beaucoup trop
d'efforts sur tic-tac Finistère
Instagram
c'est pour faire une petite embardée le
les gens qui
avaient mes amis Patrick Watson entre
autres qui avait un gros gros fanb base
de bouche à oreille naturellement
c'est développé naturellement
il y a fait un gros il décide d'aller
jouer avec Tik Tok un peu pour le fun
puis tu es fait un gros succès TikTok
puis là il rassemble un public et il va
vendre ses MT luxe très rapidement mais
c'est pas les gens qui t'habituent de
voir c'est des jeunes qui josent qui ont
pas les mêmes notions de comment
l'écouter un spectacle de Patrick Watson
il filme toutes et genre puis là ils ont
juste au 30 secondes qui a
je pense qu'il souffre pas de ça non
plus parce que là il sait que c'est fans
à lui ça aussi qui doivent se dépêcher
encore plus pour aller chercher les
billets
mais c'est tellement intéressant
de Tic-Toc
pas vraiment entendu parler c'était pas
sur TikTok puis c'est des gens qui
écoutent vraiment
la foule à réagir à crier à un moment
précis de la tonne c'est au refrain
parce que c'est ça c'est comme
et puis en même temps je faisais on peut
pas se mettant qu'on va faire on va on
va se mettre notre-dessous de bouddle on
va dire on peut pas se pencher de ça
c'est un phénomène très naturel
qui crée des gros Road Maryse c'est
intéressant de voir ça mais ça sera
jamais aussi solide que le bouchon ce
sera jamais aussi solide que le public
des Cowboys Fringants ça c'est un des
meilleurs exemples un vrai phénomène ça
dépasse les réseaux sociaux ça dépend
c'est préfet c'est pas pourquoi puis
même eux les cowboys ils savent pas ils
comprennent un peu pourquoi parce que si
ils font un style la musique qui a
beaucoup d'adresses quelque part si on
est on comprend la tonne on est là puis
le bouche-à-oreille la communauté des
cousins fringants en France etc puis là
il y a quelque chose de vraiment
extraordinaire quand tu penses de ça
c'est c'est la manière la plus solide de
faire carrément à construire sur le long
terme mais ça peut être vraiment
fulgurant aussi tu es dans le sens où
il faut effectivement faut voir la pente
douce puis travailler de cette
manière-là
le temps 0 entrevue zéro promo
jusqu'à un buzz créer une espèce de base
underground c'est que le mot se passe
puis là
pour vivre après ça une genre de ski job
moi mon enfant elle a tout de sale vie
un peu plus vite un peu même trop vite
je pense pour que je m'en que je m'en
sorte indemne
à vie privée et puis
personnelle j'ai fait des choix lequel
je peux pas jouer à la victime du tout
la victime de rien mais si je me suis
retrouvé à faire coach la voix etc c'est
comme le fallait
j'ai choisi le Québec à quelque part
j'ai choisi de faire carrière ici puis
d'embrasser toutes les sphères
d'activité d'une carrière musicale au
Québec c'est à dire aussi toucher à la
variété puis aussi au système au
showbize Québécois etc puis c'est
correct parce que on a un système en
place qui est vraiment en santé par
rapport à bien d'autres régions du monde
qu'on a pu visiter là avec erquat c'est
le la manière de protéger la langue
française le showbize Québécois est un
showbiste une espèce de
micro climat qui est vraiment spécial
c'est qu'il se tient quelque part puis
très bien vivre ta vie cette notice
pigeante pourrait manger des croûtes en
faisant le tour du monde mais tu peux
être millionnaire à faire de la musique
au Québec c'est si
j'ai comme choisi la partie québécoise
du Lot puis
j'ai mis la développement à l'étranger
du côté pendant puis là aujourd'hui je
suis en train de me dire
que la réponse c'est que j'ai fait ce
qu'il fallait que je fasse si je passe
la vie m'amenait là puis j'ai fait les
bons choix au bonne place puis
quoi faire d'autre que
je remets mon soude de Bouddha mais que
d'observer les événements se déployer
devant toi et puis de d'y aller
instinctivement des joueurs c'est c'est
le petit hamster pour moi il travaille
plus de la même en fait de travail plus
il travaille plus la même manière c'est
quand j'avais le dilemme de coach à la
voix j'ai appelé mon job Martin Léon qui
est très zen lui aussi puis d'être et
Martin il y a juste
tu vois pourquoi tu le ferais plus je
dis pour aller voir de l'intérieur
un peu le thé on est souvent en train de
chialer sur la variété sur le showbiz
puis finalement on fait rien pour le
changer
les choses ça c'est intéressant puis tu
vas être payé chaque qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire avec cet argent-là
au moins tu es cet état d'eux de deux
bonnes raisons de le faire c'était quoi
les dilemme c'était quoi l'envers de la
médaille pourquoi t'as raison ce genre
de réflexion un peu qui qui à mon sens
en ce moment 2023 avait pas pu vraiment
de poids mais dans le temps j'étais un
peu partagé entre signer un pacte avec
le diable
ouais
marginal puis dans un courant qui
justement TVA
mais c'est un peu l'équivalent de aussi
y aller par la télévision puis tu as pas
le choix d'être un petit peu
métamorphosé puis d'aller dans un temps
dans une espèce de variables
fait que mais j'avais l'intention moi de
me faufiler à traverser mais c'est quand
même un chemin que tu entreprends
[Musique]
ce chemin ce choix-là que j'ai fait en
sorte que j'ai un super gros studio
d'enregistrement à Montréal puis que je
fais on a passé 60 jours avec carquois à
faire de la musique là je dis c'est
grâce à ça peut-être une impression
aussi que c'est l'espèce de mission de
dire si j'étais hors de grande écoute
mais je représente un peu la
qui était ma grande amie qui était ma
grande amie depuis le cégepté je me
disais
dans ma tête c'était encore la petite
clavier russe avec sa tête qui jouait du
jazz puis de l'électro [__]
je dois y aller puis honnêtement encore
aujourd'hui ben du monde premièrement je
comprends pas pourquoi mais qui me
disent on t'aime beaucoup à la voix
parce que
ça fait 10 ans
mais il pense que j'étais encore là ou
que je suis Patrice Michaud je suis pas
tranquille
puis
je pense avoir marqué si j'ai dans mon
sac d'amis des gens qui travaillent qui
est des critiques de télé entre autres
et ce que c'est vraiment il y aurait
aimé ce qu'on fasse plusieurs ce que je
le fasse plusieurs saisons mais moi je
m'étais dit je le fais rien qu'une fois
rien qu'une fois puis je m'envoie puis
mon bout à ce niveau là ça revient à
entretenir le mythe
j'ai été de passage puis justement en
faisant une deuxième saison j'aurais pu
me planter un peu plus puisser
finalement on a tous dit on fait tous
des agrafes il y a personne n'est
parfait avec qui j'aurais été dévoilé
sur un autre jour puis l'autre truc
aussi qui est très très banane banane
avec ça c'est que je suis allé chercher
un large très large public évidemment
dans ces années-là en plus tu as des
trois points 5 millions c'est fou
puis là je me disais à chaque semaine
c'est tout le monde me connaît etc il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de gens qui
savaient pas du tout c'était icarquois
tu sais moi j'ai premièrement ça
m'ouvrait les yeux là les parce que moi
dans ma tête je me disais tout le monde
connaît avec podcast
tu te rends compte que c'est un
microcosme le vrai mélange du Québec là
ils sont ils sont deux cent mille notés
je sais pas c'est le nombre de disquette
que tu vas pouvoir vendre puis même pas
mes yeux dire regrouper plusieurs
artistes puis dire bon il y a peut-être
mettons
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment je tombais un peu en bas
de ma chaise puis ça m'a fait du bien
parce que je me suis rendu compte que tu
es ces êtres humains là aussi qui
travaillent à chope qui travaille un peu
partout dans la vie
c'est pas un problème je les ai pour
c'est pas le problème de société il
t'écoute pas de la musique c'est quoi
ils vivent leur vie ils sont bagarrer
puis si tu es moindrement c'était une
personnalité un peu attachante ou
charismatique etc ils vont apprécier ils
vont être curieux c'est là que je me
suis mis à vendre des 80000 90 000
copies d'albums dans ces années-là on va
aller encore des albums
ok les gens ils ont juste besoin des
fois de découvrir quelque part
d'aller chercher ça mais qu'est-ce que
tu présentes
c'est contrairement au cowboy par
exemple je prends souvent l'exemple des
corbeilles mais c'est donc nous allons
jouer avec Aqua pas beaucoup à Radio
donc c'est normal aussi qu'il y a un
certain
de la population qui vivent vraiment
avec tes énergies c'est quoi etc
qui sont pas nécessairement curieux mais
qui réussit quand même à percer leur
chambre des cours puis là c'est ça qui
est le fun c'est que quand on réussit ça
c'est des gens qui justement qui sont
exposés à ce qu'on leur présente laisse
un peu leur présenter quelque chose d'un
petit peu différent puis qui a juste une
coupe là dedans qui font hacker
de manière de faire de la musique qui se
suivent puis homme et crimes ça
m'intéresse
c'est que ça va rester ça va rester une
commercialisation qui sera qui sera pas
100% comme on disait pur le thé au
niveau du bouche à oreille mais il y a
quand même s'il y a pourcentage X de un
cathodique qui ont découvert par la
biais de la télé par exemple qui ont
tellement tripé qui se mettent à devenir
du bouche-à-oreille organique c'est là
que je me disais on a tout au fil du
temps on réfléchit un peu à ça c'est
mais il y a des il y a des atouts
majeurs pour une pour une le rayonnement
d'une carrière puis il va rester que les
choses indénosables sont surtout comment
tu démènes sur scène parce que tu
essaies de venir le seul truc tangible
maintenant la façon d'écouter la musique
c'est un peu free fall avec les les les
applications de streaming etc
si tu veux défendre un show comme du
monde les gens pas vraiment de quoi ils
vont en parler aujourd'hui
puis l'autre à faire c'est le charisme
quelque part-il
le talent tu l'as pas le charisme ça
peut être un peu compliqué mais ça finit
un petit peu par se développer dans
une question d'attitude et je parlais
tantôt je parle de Bouddha depuis le
côté zen la phase et c'est le côté genre
pas être toujours en train de penser
puis d'être vraiment détendu d'être
ouvert du cœur d'aller voir les gens
quand tu fais une autre vue c'était
vraiment dans ton mental puis tu es un
peu plus tu fais juste des concepts ça
se passe pour être ça ça marche pas mais
c'était super Go wit de flow
le mot se passe aussi puis les les
médias en tant que tels vont vouloir ils
vont être ils vont s'attacher un peu à
toi et on voulait être invité ici c'est
ça c'est comme ça que tu gravis les
échelons pas mal
les différences aussi entre évolué en
tant que groupe en tant qu'artiste je
pense c'est plus facile quand même si
maintenant le groupe de plus attiré les
fans de musique tandis que c'est quand
tu es une personne quand tu viens de
personnalité qui est des gens aussi qui
vont s'attacher parce qu'ils justement
être drôle ou tu sais parce qu'il trouve
charismatique parce qu'il parce qu'il
aime la personne ça amène tout un autre
loto
puis en même temps il va rester que la
matière première c'est la musique pareil
moi avoir une comme je dirais donc je me
tire dans le pire disant ça mais bon
avoir une une personnalité flamboyante
puis drôle toute seule mais si tu fais
de la musique
complètement niché vraiment tu es
musiques actuelles tu vois tu vois je
dis pas que ça va pas marcher mais tu
vas rester quand même dans un créneau
qui est celui-là tu peux pas t'attendre
c'est correct il faut être donc ça
m'amène à la lucidité aussi il faut être
lucide qu'est-ce qu'on veut en fait
c'est que les objectifs en faisant de la
musique
actuelle
l'accueil
non mais j'allais dire
la lucidité ça vient beaucoup aussi avec
ce genre d'expérience là de comme ce que
j'ai pu faire à la voix entre autres
c'est ça a été une grosse grosse dose de
de lucidité de voir ok ok la Toile du
Québec puis là elle est où les personnes
qui connaissent Philippe
comme moi j'ai appris que moi j'adore la
musique que j'aime c'est super
c'est il y a des déclinaisons partout
puis c'est c'est
compartimenter mais en tout cas ça pour
dire que ça m'a fait ça m'a fait du bien
dans mon développement de carrière
quelque part de faire ça
les épaules sont relâchés un peu quand
même à faire carquois est-ce que métier
est-ce que justement la création du
mythe a fait en sorte que vous êtes en
studio qui est le Lego il faut que la
prochaine soit bon parce que là les gens
nous attire les gens qui ont un certain
standards car quoi il y a le monde ne
s'attendent de ce que ça soit sur une
bande alors il y a une certaine forme
le public aurait jamais la barre aussi
haute que nous autres
Carquest ban de méloman c'est un bande
de musicien 5 têtes complètement
différentes fait que quand on
travaillait les seules personnes qu'on
devait charmer c'est nous-mêmes le type
il fallait absolument qu'on se rende à
une place au
pied de façon une année cette chanson là
est bonne ou infinie où on pense que
c'est cool c'est un autre goût etc
je pense qu'on est dû à satisfaire c'est
tout un autre avantage à qui parle
mais il y avait aussi un gros travail
que je pense avoir été un des acteurs de
qui a amené ce concept là mais fallait
vraiment
vraiment y aller avec le coeur vous
désactiver le petit hamster je suis
vraiment là dedans je suis beaucoup
là-dedans
j'ai pris sur la réaction la future
réaction des gens jusqu'à
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui si on
t'aide pour l'album dans la seconde qui
sort ce vendredi je sais pas comment
partir
on sait
donner comme des filles de rentrer au
studio à chaque jour avec aucune idée
préconçue donc aucune chanson à
présenter au God ouais c'est un rêve etc
rien
pour les derniers albums
ou des bribes de chansons ou j'ai une
chanson complète
je me rappelle d'avoir fait une liste de
22 rifs différents pour les chemins de
verre avec Franck là on était beaucoup
en tournée en Europe dans ces années là
bon tu as toujours à la frite en
banlieue de Paris un super beau studio
mythique d'enregistrement qui est
propriétaire dont le propriétaire est un
ami Olivier blocliné qui est le pour la
petite histoire le de Marie jotériot
puis
on était là on dormait là c'est un
manoir il y a plein de charmilles 21
pièces je pense puis on avait fait dans
la cuisine en buvant du rouge une liste
de 22 rêves puis on dit ok on va faire
ça
peut être par jour pendant 22 jours ben
c'est entrecoupé de tourner etc mais
puis il faudrait que le matin on
commence dessus puis le soir idéalement
il y aurait des mots puis que tout soit
TP dans Ça c'est ça les chemins de base
ça c'est définir finir
on a bien évidemment pas réussi mais on
a quand même plusieurs fêtes plusieurs
dons une de mes préférées de karko c'est
moi léger elle est partie le matin et
puis le soir il y avait des mots dessus
des paroles il y avait rien il y avait
rien du tout puis comme d'habitude on
écrit souvent les mots après avec à quoi
ça a toujours été comme ça ben même avec
mes enfants
on était très dans l'arrangement tout le
temps c'est quasiment ce qui presse
c'est la compo musicale la mélodie puis
les arrangements après ça on écoute ce
qu'on dit ça nous fait penser à tel
sujet puis on écrit là-dessus ok c'est
notre façon de travailler puis ça crée
une belle je trouve une espèce de
homogénéité entre les mots puis la
musique mais c'est quand même un
casse-tête parce qu'il faut que tu
écrives les mots de que ça rentre au
bonne place
comment ça se faisait mettons si vous
rentrez avec aucune des préconçues puis
là j'imagine que c'est suite si vous
prêtez au jeu pour de vrai et pas de
pré-réflexion avant d'arriver ça
s'article comment
les premières journées on disait quel
tempo
on aimerait jouer ici
97 on part on part là dessus puis là
souvent Steph Piou Julien faisait des
beats des fois moi j'ai dans ma mes
années sabbatique que j'ai prise avant
avant les deux derniers albums j'ai
beaucoup creusé les scènes et les
simples
je me saoule comme gosser on partait ses
affaires je savais des vieux quatuor à
corde danois de vinyle de mon père
c'est un flou là
devenait des tonnes
vous le voyez mettons se transformer au
la journée en fait moi le but là ça va
être une belle précision que je vais
faire le puis je pense que je vois la
reprendre pour d'autres entrevues
le but était pas de composer à gagne
tant que ça ok le but pour moi premier
était que tout le monde soit dans un
état
de vide complet T2 de pas savoir ce qui
s'en vient c'est toute une démarche
encore un peu philosophique et puis
spirituelle à quelque part de pas
pouvoir utiliser son cerveau c'est OK
parce qu'on est souvent temps de
tendance à un outil extraordinaire le
cerveau mais pour la création des fois
il est souvent des jambes
sur le moment puis parle billet d'une
déboulade
qui peuplent
si bémol la cloche principalement
le trou gosse autour du cinéma les
accords qui partent mais là t'es dans ta
pull notion du temps et de toute manière
tu es comme
ça devient quelque chose ça a vraiment
été vraiment
puis il y a des moments où on était
craqué mes rêves on allait dîner quand
on réécoutait à présidente
prouvé qu'on était absorbé c'est puis
qu'on était dans la création un peu
qu'il y avait pas de concepts fréquentés
de référence à qui on veut que ça sonne
un peu comme ça où on veut que c'était
il a fallu travailler fort pour pas
tomber là-dedans parce que si on a des
réflexes surtout François puis moi on
travaille demain depuis des années ah
oui tel album de Bowie
par sonner comme quand tu travailles en
référence trop précise ça peut juste
comme mettre des contraintes
trop contraignant la création pour rien
finalement
je sais pas si c'est de la paresse ou du
moins de l'efficacité mais ça peut être
plus facile pour le commun immortel et
comprendre l'idée que tu as dans tête
c'est quand même un raccourci
tu te rappelles
tout le monde sait mais un petit peu
trop et moi j'ai commencé le travail
avec erquan en donnant beaucoup beaucoup
de de Love à mon ami Julien sago qui lui
est doté d'un talent hors norme c'est
que il y a
il n'y a pas de référence
ces idées sont pures sont toujours peu
ils sont tout le temps à l'inverse de ce
que moi j'aurais fait instinctivement
tout le temps
en vert puis c'est une oh non je pense
visuel comme la musique ou la danse etc
c'est ça une valeur c'est la plus grande
valeur je pensais quand tu as des idées
qui sont singulières qui ont qui ont pas
été
teintées par d'autres choses Julien est
un créateur
fait que souvent
ça s'amène à des affaires vraiment plus
abstraites parce que tu arrives plus à y
arriver mal à expliquer aussi on va
faire un truc comme ça
au début les dégâts impatients comme
François la fontaine n'importe quoi ça
marchera pas au final on le sait que
c'était cœur hein mais il faut donc faut
être patient il faut désactiver le
cerveau faut être dans le moment présent
puis il faut avoir le luxe d'avoir un
studio pour faire ça l'album dans la
seconde des années 70 à écouter au
dessus d'un million certains c'est sûr
que vous avez pris pour être des
semaines et des semaines et des heures
et des heures et des c'est comme avec
imagine tout seul sur du temple pour ce
projet là on a fait 28 sessions pour
tout avec Ben du stock dedans puis des
fois même des sessions oui ou il y a
plusieurs James
qui font l'unanimité il y en avait un Q8
OK puis le phénomène 9e qui était
instrumental qui s'est rajouté
quand même le filtre est assis
nous autres on est avec filtre
non mais en même temps pour la création
c'est ça je pense que c'est ça qui est
beau d'un monstre synthèse puis c'est
comme il faut savoir le dompter le gérer
c'est vraiment de l'harmonie dans le
studio la monite c'est quelque chose
qu'on
société en général je pense qu'il manque
énormément d'harmonie puis de toutes les
musiciens comprend pas mal cette affaire
si c'est le même terme que l'harmonie
dans la cour d'école mettons l'harmonie
il faut que ça vibre ensemble pour qu'on
se respecte on soit capable d'être en
phase puis dans un studio enregistrement
c'est pas le mal le mot le plus
important car tu réalises un disque que
tout le monde lui intervenants les
artistes
soient vraiment bien sur le X puis en
phase avec tout le monde autour
c'est vraiment un vrai bain dans le sens
que tout le monde a un apport dans la
création puis dans le son de cette bande
c'est pas logique
la fontaine qui allait un petit peu trop
vite pour au rythme des autres puis là
c'est ça qu'on voulait recasser aussi
c'est le côté
moi je pense à TDA puis Franck est
littéralement télérages
qui court vite
tu as des créateurs de grands talents en
a rien qui sont vraiment moins pas sur
le même pays en même temps tu la pose
par rapport à Julien Sagon 30 aurait
fait un gros travail parce que lui sa
carrière solo il a appris à gérer ben
des affaires qui gérait pas avant des
budgets de prod des idées de la
réalisation du mix de vocabulaire
comment s'adresser aux gens comment dire
ce que tu aimes ce que tu aimes pas etc
ça change beaucoup la donne dans le
temps de car quoi la première batch là
il c'était tout encore plus paru que
c'est là que
c'est beau comme ça petit là il y a
vraiment des des idées plus capables
puis toi qui était pendant
10 ans même plus le truc est a été
justement en solo puis qui est vraiment
que en studio il a pris le dernier mot
c'est toi je veux dire
à un mode puisque 5 personnes c'est des
compromis aussi c'est c'est facile ou ça
a été un défi
ça restera toujours un défi là quelque
part parce que c'est que la création
d'une oeuvre puis si on veut on y met du
sien puis on est on veut que ça soit
mais non parce que c'est ça avec
carquois premièrement tu te mets dans un
mode de base tu fais que ça change
beaucoup la donne pas je vais pas être
dictateur d'idées puis il y a quelque
chose qui change beaucoup la donne en ce
moment pour cette opération si c'est que
là au risque de me répéter on
revient mais dans une zone de plaisir
absolu et de d'absence de développement
de carrière on est plus en train de tu
es dans le temps on était menotté
littéralement les 5 ensemble étaient
avec notre salaire ou de nos familles
etc tout le monde travaillait pour que
c'est
tourner album tourner puis on n'était
pas assez je dirais zen et conscient à
cette époque là pour comprendre
pour le plaisir finalement on le fait
pour peut-être la meilleure raison du
monde c'est-à-dire pas d'attente on fait
la musique
ça laisse les portes ouvertes justement
aux idées des autres il y a moins de
passer ma tonne il faut que ça va passer
à Radio budgétaire il y a plus de jamais
eu ces grosses batailles là mais il y
aurait pu mettre puis quand tu fais
quelque chose avec cet état d'esprit là
celui de waouh on le fait pour c'est un
cadeau du ciel si on va ça va être juste
la fin mais généralement tout arrive
c'est ce que j'apprends avec le lâcher
prise puis avec les études que je fais
en spiritualité c'est ainsi c'est comme
le côté
[Musique]
la vie la vie va vibrer avec toi si tu
prends le temps de vivre avec elle si tu
allais salé
à bonne place et c'est pas de contrôler
rien que là on est dans cette zone là
parce que on est rendu là aussi tu es
les journalistes demandent souvent aussi
pourquoi pourquoi là pourquoi maintenant
c'est comme je sais pas ce que parce que
parce que ça aurait pu se faire avancer
ça donne comme ça tu as pas de pourquoi
on peut pas le dire on aura fait toutes
nos affaires c'est les quatre albums sur
l'eau que j'ai fait les quatre albums
que je viens en fait toutes les tournées
à faire c'est le retour de François
Lafontaine dans ma vie professionnelle
avec quand la nuit tombe on avant
dernier disque puis la tournée qui a
suivi en fait on a couru réalisé le ciel
est au plancher mon dernier album j'ai
fait 150 choux de rock avec moi puis
Stéphane remplaçait Marc-André Laroque
aussi mon mon batteur des fois on se
retrouve à l'écart quoi c'est comme
c'est toutes des marches là on est rendu
là on est rendu le X car quoi on revient
on dirait que
laisser l'espace c'est quelque chose qui
revient beaucoup le gars quand on parle
de créativité sur le podcast
pour que ça ça se passe on dirait que la
créativité jaillit ne peut pas jaillir
en fait si il y a pas de place pour que
j'aille là on dirait que c'est ça que tu
expliques
je me sens plus de même
si
c'était trop pressé si tu es
préoccupé sur tes antennes sortent pas
c'est faut savoir comment
faut savoir se mettre dans l'état
d'esprit pour être capable de s'envoler
le type you de capter les la création
existent pas à l'intérieur de soi et à
l'existence dans l'énergie vitale c'est
ça devient fucky mésotérique mon enfant
mais c'est vrai puis c'est sûr le fameux
chic que tu parlais c'est de l'album
tourné album tourné album tourné tu te
laisses pas ce temps-là tu laisses pas
cet espace là dans le moment
on devient aussi très bon dans dans un
moment
c'est de confiance confiance
les antennes sont connectés sur ta
confiance en toi aussi beaucoup là
est-ce que je ce que je me sentais il y
a une espèce de Momentum année où tu vas
jouer je sais pas pourquoi mais hier on
était à l'Escaut à l'Esco griffer on va
de retour dans un bar puis il y a des
moments où
je sais pas pourquoi mais tu es en train
de jouer quelque chose
cette zone là peut arriver
sportadiquement ça peut arriver si tu
traces tu médites un peu petite mais
vraiment dans une zone de vibration mais
aussi ça peut arriver dans un moment
quand tu es en train de faire tu sais
pas pourquoi mais tu es dans un
mouvement là puis là tout de suite
c'était carrément
dans le rythme c'est album tourné album
tourné comme il y a quelque chose qui
marche pas c'est dès qu'une notion
routinière qui s'installe puis il y a
une pression de
deadline date butoir etc c'est comme
mais en même temps les artistes on va
toujours avoir besoin de cette beauté de
cul aussi
rien sortir il faut que mener les gens
qui qui font ce métier-là de production
c'est un vrai métier de
commercialisation d'albums ils ont
besoin de mener dans le calendrier et
puis d'avancer psychool comme ça fait
que les carcans étaient justement dans
cette zone vraiment vaporise là de
création permanent il y a eu un meeting
offert ok là faut qu'un avril le master
soit livré puis qu'on fasse pas les
vinyles qu'on puisse faire nos chauds
qui sont déjà annoncés etc on a on avait
comme un échantillon
je pense qu'on a fait assez correct
parce que sinon tu peux
me rajouter
de David de Michel-Ange plutôt c'est pas
une mygale
[Musique]
est-ce que tu es capable de l'appliquer
à aujourd'hui à une sortie d'album ou
encore sous stressant aujourd'hui un
album refait tout ce qu'on fait mais
tout ce que moi je veux parler pour moi
les gars ils sont les gars
ils font mal leur vie comme ils veulent
mais moi toute ma vie est devenue
spirituelle à quelque part puis tout ce
qu'il faut faire c'est tout ce que je
m'ennuie ici je me disais que ça va être
la fin je désactive tout ce qui pourrait
être avec tout d'un coup que je signais
rien mais tout d'un coup
ces questions là je les observe de loin
et on a tout le temps un dialogue mental
en tête non-stop soit capable de
l'observer mais
je trouve ça gros comme terme
spiritualité sur les gens ils font le
soupe mais au final ce n'est que
être capable de
d'être soi-même à l'intérieur de soi
d'observer tout ce qui se déroule puis
de le faire pour les bonnes raisons de
pas être en train de
c'est comme par exemple être spirituel
dans ton travail c'est prendre
conscience de pourquoi tu es en train de
le faire tu es bye bye à la grande
majorité des gens vont travailler pour
gagner quelque chose
tandis que là on devrait tous être en
train de travailler pour donner avoir
donné quelque chose servir à quelque
chose et puis être ça peut être très
pragmatique genre je suis plombier je
vise des tuyaux
c'est ça
mais donc on devrait être dans une
démarche de de bien-être absolument à
l'intérieur de soi puis de trouver que
n'importe quel métier est extraordinaire
c'est merveilleux en fait c'est juste ça
c'est comme c'est merveilleux de toutes
puis quand tu arrives pour faire ton
métier comme la musique par exemple puis
que tu arrives sur scène en disant waouh
j'ai aucune idée de ce qui va se passer
mais
bon je sens que ça doit faire peut-être
je sais pas moi ça ça un chou que je
fais je faisais sans les derniers choses
solo dans zone de zénitude
mais il y a quelque chose qui change les
gens ils viennent te voir après ils sont
comme dans une zone parce que ils t'ont
vu
ça va de l'ordre de quand mettons qu'il
y a quelqu'un qui rentre dans pièce qui
est en tabarnak on a on n'a pas besoin
de s'échanger un seul mot on le sait on
file mais cela c'est des zones qu'on
envoie aux autres ça nous appartient
c'est bien ça c'est notre responsabilité
de tourner ça au positif d'être vraiment
dans la béatitude en gratitude d'être
bien tiens puis en spectacle je dis
souvent quand je donne des conférences
le public est un miroir de toi c'est la
une des plus grandes vérités que j'ai eu
à que j'ai pu apprendre avec les mises
anciens avec les Michel il va appeler
Richard c'est bien de ce monde avec qui
j'ai travaillé c'est comme si tes
poignée du cul public et poignée du cul
c'était fauché le public va être oui
comment tu voudrais
incarne ce que tu voudrais avoir devant
toi puis la musique s'il y a rien de
plus beau que ça parce que c'est
invisible ça se déploie au moment où tu
étais en train de fatiguer et quelque
chose de hyper
jouissifs spirituelle avec la musique de
notre côté en train de la jouer puis tu
perds comme j'expliquais hier soir
t'aider dans ta zone comme le dieu a les
grands musiciens jazz qui a mené de
tomber là il y arrivait dans dans le hit
et la zone puis le second
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que tu es dans
cette démarche es-tu un début tu as eu
des clics
de l'ordre de ma vie personnelle qui
était que j'ai foutu en la complètement
après la fin des tournées des grandes
artères je me suis séparé j'avais vécu
une double vie j'étais dans une zone
complètement factable de moi-même à côté
de mes pompes c'est ça c'était un effet
secondaire du succès ou c'est pas la
femme
en cours du succès on est là sans filtre
on peut tout dire je pense aussi que
j'extériorisais des insatisfactions à
l'intérieur de moi la Phrase psychologue
assez simple mais pouvais pas ça
explique
c'est ça mais et puis encore une fois le
système d'insatisfaction et
il est souvent contrôlé par ton Esprit
puis par qui tu penses que tu es mais
dans le fond que tu n'es pas là ça c'est
la ça va être un peu la boîte de Pandore
que je viens d'ouvrir dans les dernières
années par rapport à la spiritualité
c'est comprendre qui tu es vraiment un
type c'est nous à l'intérieur de nous
l'homme ou l'esprit c'est c'est
la plus
c'est l'entité qui est complètement en
arrière de tout ça c'est parce que tu
apprends très vite à comprendre que même
quand tu dis ah j'aurais dû appeler Fred
hier soir parce que j'ai pas appelé
frère merci
j'arrive plus à dormir toutes ces
questions là même des fois il y a une
question puis il y a une autre personne
qui répondent on a ça incessamment mais
l'homme c'est c'est
l'entité qui observe ses affaires tu es
capable de tu es capable de te rendre
compte vite que
quelques
une entité à l'intérieur de toi-même tu
étais pas ton corps puis tu es pas ton
esprit tu es pas ton mental c'était
comme tu es quelque chose tu es une
énergie qui est là si c'est Michael
Seigneur que j'ai que j'adore que
j'étudie beaucoup là j'allais aller à
tout le monde allez lire
entre autres la lampe délivrée de
Michael singer c'est comme c'est une
Bible c'est extraordinaire mais il
explique un menu dans une conférence
c'est que si on te mettait un rideau
autour de la du coup là puis tu es
couché puis là avec tous les les outils
de médecine moderne Angel plus on
t'enlève une jambe et on enlève une
autre jambe plug les poumons seraient
respirateurs artificiels puis toi tu
sais pas tu sais rien elle était
complètement gelé puis et dis-moi si je
suis à côté de toi
puis jusqu'au moment où un monite c'est
un même plus de corps petit gamin est
encore là
une entité qui est un peu indestructible
qui est linké bien sûr à la tête mais il
te montre à travers ses livres magazine
comme quoi aussi tu es capable de
désactiver quand tu
parce qu'on est souvent connecté avec
l'essence quand tu vas au cinéma par
exemple un d'oublier que tu es danse
dans une pièce noire quand ok d'être
dans une pièce noire avec 400 personnes
puis regarder d'oublier que tu es là
puis l'essence qui est toute panique et
ensemble mais s'il y a quelque chose qui
gosse dans le film tout ça continue à
travailler mais à l'intérieur de ce que
je trouve pas ça si bon que ça c'est là
il y a quand même ça se détache c'est
totalement
d'esprit qui se détache mais l'entité
qui est l'homme aidait encore plus
derrière elle est comme
et comme en arrière de soi je
commencerais pas à vous expliquer tout
ça ça va être trop long mais j'aime
beaucoup cette démarche et donc j'étais
dans une période de crise j'ai commencé
à prendre des cours de méditation avec
mon ami Martin Léon qui m'a ramassé
cette cuillère c'est mon plus grand
confident on a on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de moments lui c'est un manteau de
vraiment sexuel etc puis à partir de la
micro de méditation j'ai commencé
vraiment à être intéressé à ça plus là
je commence à lire des moines bouddhisme
des grands penseurs
du moment présent c'est un délit qui m'a
le plus bousculé extraordinaire
plaidoyer pour le bonheur de Matthieu
Ricard ça c'était mes premières lectures
puis ce qui est drôle dans mon cas moi
je suis un espèce de parenthèse c'est
que mon père était prêtre
curé puis lui il y a des froquets et
quitter la prêtrice pour fonder une
famille
l'enseignement était beaucoup dans
l'enseignement mais il y avait quand
même une vie spirituelle puis moi je
fais un quasiment
je me retrouve après je sais quand même
d'une certaine manière de vivre un
village
puis juste chanter des chansons tu sais
ça sert aussi à faire voyager les gens
la chanson tout ça c'est
spécial si je me suis retrouvé et puis
je suis passionné c'est un peu
monomaniaque dans la ville quand je
tripes quelque chose très peu trop fort
ce que du temps avec le chien
j'ai pris des cours de respiration des
cours de lecture je fais du yoga comme
ça a pas de sens
en fait on est tous sous écoute là mais
chacun Instagram puis là je vais des
podcasts de bien-être c'est quand même
1h30
mais je pense que la société a
énormément besoin de comme vous êtes en
taux d'harmonie puis depuis des
merveillement oublie j'en oublie ça le
cerveau est un outil extraordinaire et
on a comme Google à l'intérieur de nous
autres mais il faut pas que Google
prenne possession de ton coeur de ton
énergie puis on devrait être en train de
Chucker les cornes orange à Montréal
physique
de trouver ça quasiment le fun de
regarder quand on arrange
c'est l'autre niveau
il y avait des on faisait des la promo
qu'il y avait coupé le la ligne d'eau
font des de la qui font la caduc puis il
travaille fort et on chauffe il faisait
42 et si c'est bien là la femme a dit
qu'il est devant nous qui gère un peu le
chantier
vraiment désolé un couple maintenant
alors 40 on va avoir une belle ligne
d'eau neuf puis était comme moi si tout
le monde était comme c'était
là la rue puis réparer là comme du monde
faut s'émerveiller de ça qu'il porte
c'est fou quand même un déclic comme ça
pas sur le tort mais toi tu sais c'est
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu revois
mettons les
les périodes justement qui t'ont amené
là comme en disant ah si j'avais eu ces
outils là à ce moment-là il y aurait
bien des affaires ce serait peut-être
différemment
je suis rendu là parce qu'il fallait que
je me rende là mais des fois tu revois
tout ça en direct avec ce que je sais
maintenant ou ce que j'incarne
maintenant sur été différent la faire
c'est que je suis pas en mesure de dire
que ça aurait été différent pour la
simple et bonne raison que ce qui est
drôle aussi de la notion de lâcher prise
ce que les gens comprennent pas trop je
pense puisque je comprenais pas avant
c'est que malgré le fait que tu penses
contrôler quelque chose avec ta tête
va se dérouler comme à quelque part
comme ton destin doit être déroulé c'est
c'est un gros gap à avaler le je sais
que c'est une grosse pilule à avaler
mais au final tu peux faire plein de
mauvais choix c'est clair et tu peux
utiliser la notion de karma finalement
c'est d'essayer de trop prendre le
contrôle de ta vie puis de t'en aller
dans le champ la vie va toujours être
plus intelligente que toi type que nous
que nous tous ça fait 13 points 9
milliards et demi milliards d'années que
fait Sachie je trouve ça drôle même ce
qui se passe avec les feux de forêt et
puis avec les changements climatiques
puis les gens sont comme faut sauver la
planète mais la planète elle roule il y
en a eu des feux de forêts dans les 13 -
9 milliards d'années il y en a eu plein
mais l'être humain lui il va il s'en va
dans le beurre le type l'être humain il
est pas conscient en ce moment tu sais
on va continuer à pomper du gaz pour
faire plus d'un milliard de dollars où
on veut gagner du territoire de façon
impérialiste comme Poutine aller
chercher du terrain pour être je sais
pas moi il va avoir plus c'est c'est que
de la poussière d'étoiles puis même
notre corps on est nos atomes la table
qui est là ça a pris une étoile qui
explose si Jean 10 milliards d'années
pour faire du bois c'est quand même ok
mais en tout temps et puis moi je joue
beaucoup golf je dois être un peu de
golfe des fois je joue avec des avec des
pages neuves de ligue ceux qui sont
fâchés qui savent le bal dans le bois
puis ils sont caractéristiques
dans un univers un expansion tu sais
ton driver qui coûte 800 pièces il fait
un graphite ça a pris comme des Super
Nova c'est comme calcul sur même pas
capable d'être capable de faire la
formule mathématique pour faire du
fucking graphite
la vie va être plus haute que tout est
là
je vais avoir deux coups de plus sur ma
carte c'est pas grave mais les gens ils
les gens vivent vraiment dans leur tête
dans performance puis dans le stress
puis dans la résistance c'est un terme
qui est vraiment important souvent en
spiritualité c'est la résistance c'est
le stress les grands penseurs disent le
stress existe pas le stress c'est le
stress et le flot de la vie c'est le
degré de résistance que toi tu vas
appliquer sur les événements de ta vie
qui va faire le stress un petit
responsable de ton stress c'est ça
t'appartient c'est juste toi qui ferme
le truc qui qui bouge le trou de la
balle ou pas le type qui fait
c'est intéressant cette notion là parce
qu'on est on joue beaucoup à la victime
j'aime pas mon métier et puis à taper là
ton métier chiffre d'affaires le fait
que tu sois vivant sur une planète dans
un univers une expansion c'est un autre
pays
[Musique]
si tu laisses circuler l'énergie à
l'intérieur de toi puis que tu vois
toute la vie d'un autre et que tu t'es
merveilles comme un enfant de 2 ans avec
une fleur puis il va regarder ça va être
tellement dans
la beauté puis il y a plus de secondes
puis 2 minutes qui roule tu vas voir
vraiment tu vas peut-être rentrer à Job
le lendemain avec une autre patente et
une autre vision que si je pourrais
faire pour améliorer mon sang puis
l'autre affaire avec le lâcher prise ça
revient un peu à ce que je disais tantôt
par rapport au spectacle c'est que si tu
vas à job avec le cœur ouvert en disant
moi je suis là pour aider maintenant
pour faire ce que j'ai à faire parce que
je vais bien dans ma vie à l'extérieur
et je suis bien
tu resteras pas dans une très longtemps
tu vas graver les échelons tu vas donner
pas trop tu vas t'ouvrir toute la vie va
te prendre tu vas finir à taille d'une
entreprise milliardaire
what the fuck j'en veux même pas j'ai
même pas besoin moins d'argent mais ça
ça fait ça souvent elle est beaucoup
d'histoires la plupart des histoires de
succès c'est des hasards et des
successions mais c'est des circonstances
c'est des gens qui étaient à la bonne
place au bon moment mais qui était aussi
justement ouverts
quelque chose puis l'ont saisie le c'est
plus que comme mon but c'est d'être si
haut puis je vois c'est juste comme je
sais pas exactement mais tant que je
fais un parallèle avec le podcast qui
est sur une échelle scoop peu importe
sur quelle échelle de succès que ça se
trouve mais tu sais c'était comme on a
le goût de rencontrer du monde on a le
goût de parler avec du monde on veut
juste le faire on va les inviter puis on
va voir des conversations puis là
incrément mais ça intéresse du monde
dans le fond pitié dans au final c'est
pas fou de passer quelque chose qui nous
intéresse
du monde d'avoir une conversation que
nous on trouve intéressante même chose
pour la musique ça fait la boucle de ce
que disait tantôt c'est ton état
d'esprit au moment où tu fais tu fais
dans une démarche de
l'équivalent de devenir de vouloir
devenir sillon tandis que l'on fait pour
le plaisir mais oui et puis je serai pas
surpris qu'il se passe bien des affaires
jouant avec la vie c'est jouant avec
elle elle file la fait son affaire
exactement en musique je trouve que
c'est je trouve que tout le temps des
exemples dans le sens que c'est tout le
temps la musique la plus honnête je
trouve la plus la plus qui qui finit par
joindre le monde puis surtout quand on
tient on parlait de long terme de
construire quelque chose c'est c'est
faut que ça de calquer quelque chose ou
de de
références
de pop de chansons pop radiophoniques
puis non même que dans le juste au
Québec tu regardes dans le passé des
grands succès comme était Vallières on
va s'aimer encore il voulait même pas
mettre son disque et puis c'est une
[Musique]
rien c'est
arrivé puis souvent les meilleurs
chansons le en plus vous êtes des
missing aussi
ont tendance à penser que ça a été écrit
par d'autres latino sont arrivées de
façon fulgurante puis oh mon Dieu si
finalement c'est c'est celle qui reste
le plus longtemps à travers les années
dans ton PC de spectacle
qui était écrit à la soie de ton front
en disant que j'écrive la toux du siècle
est arrivé comme ça puis c'est pointé
dans les dernières années j'ai ce
phénomène-là m'intéressait beaucoup j'ai
comme essayer de creuser
j'essayais de me
me prédisposer à la chanson figurante
c'est ça moi ça a été comme une étude
sur le dernier album le ciel est au
plancher puis quand la nuit tombe j'ai
plus de chansons figurantes que dans
tous les autres albums j'ai fait dans
toute ma vie car quoi est compris parce
que je méditais beaucoup avant de me
mettre en je méditais avant de me mettre
à travailler puis j'utilisais des
stratagèmes pour désactiver mon cerveau
genre les deux derniers albums je les ai
composé au piano j'avais perdu un peu
mon jeu de piano j'avais commencé dans
le temps quand j'étais tout jeune j'ai
pris beaucoup de cours de piano et que
puis j'essaie de travailler dans le noir
le soir
dans quelle tonalité je jouais mais
jouer des affaires puis j'étais vraiment
dans une zone où mon cerveau est perdu
ses repères
automatiquement un peu dans le coeur
puis
[Musique]
ça a fonctionné c'est vraiment mais ce
prix c'est comme si on oublie des fois
une étape importante à la création c'est
l'approche à la création
[Musique]
désactive un peu toutes ces écoutes le
silence un bout la presse pas
à midi ça me prend tout absolument que
c'est là que c'est
la minute après avoir dropé ton
cellulaire après avoir refusé ton fils
une quatorzième fois
ça peut déjouer parce que là tu es comme
tes prix de cours pas de surprise je
disais souvent notre vie que c'était
quand j'étais très très fatigué que
j'écrivais les meilleures chansons parce
que tout écrasé
que tu joues c'est pas c'est pas du tout
toi qui est en train de faire c'est
comme l'énergie photo
possède puis généralement foque toutes
les chiens ça devient mauvais mais il y
a eu un petit éclair à manique et passée
c'est drôle ça c'est concept-là parce
que tu sais qu'on capte quelque chose
parce que c'est une des choses que mon
prof de guitares du Cégep de 15 ans
disait la musique elle existe il faut
juste que comme sur la table le titre
puis je trouve ça vraiment beau de
manière de
mais si tu comprends assez vite aussi
comme dans les dans les lectures que je
fais c'est dans mes études que c'est pas
juste la musique c'est toutes les
connaissances du monde [__] il y a des
des grands grands grands grands penseurs
qui arrivent à faire le tour même
Einstein puis un des gars qui m'a le
plus secouer dans une dernière année le
seul bonhomme qui est décédé depuis très
longtemps
Krishnamurti qui s'appelle un grand
penseur indien puis lui il dit
la plus grande horloge c'est
[Musique]
que quand tu penses tout savoir tu es
dans vraiment tu es à côté tes pompes
c'est d'être dans un flot
énergie d'énergie peut-être vraiment
bien peut-être la réponse à votre
manifester devant toi puis finalement la
revient un peu à dire la vie est plus
intelligente que toi parce que toutes
les toutes les formules mathématiques
existent déjà dans le fond
les règles de l'univers existent mais
les règles de l'univers ils sont gérés
par la physique quantique puis ça c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment
extraordinaire parce que les
mathématiciens sont rendus en train de
développer sa valeur puis de décider de
le charter de le titre de
l'expliquer mais il y a quelque chose
qui est vraiment plus fort et la
physique quantique
en fait c'est tout ce qui est pas
en anglais de newtonienne de Newton de
la pensée newtonienne qui est comme
genre de plus de fondcats
qui se peut que tu viens dans
l'infiniment petit le tout
à observer un atome puis dire que quand
l'énergie de un autre corps s'approche
mettons quand le scientifique
s'approchait de la tombe il faisait
disparaître lui son énergie faisait
disparaître des électrons qui
réapparaissaient l'autre barre
ça sera jamais un calcul ça sera pas
possible de faire un calcul précis comme
les vagues de la marque étudier ok je
pense qu'il au 13.8 secondes ça marche
pas tout le temps foutu ça va être donc
le calcul est impossible
c'est
extraordinaire parce que quand tu penses
à cela elle a vraiment que la vie comme
ça tu as appris je reviens à poussière
d'étoiles mettez ça a pris tout ça ça a
pris une masse d'hydrogène qui a mené
qui pète que surchauffé qui a pété ça
crée un autre atome ça a créé un autre
atome ça a créé notre atome là il y en a
juste 16 des atomes périodique avant que
ça devienne quelque chose de plus lourd
avant c'est juste des gaz ça devient le
faire et puis à partir des métaux lourds
mais ça prend des planètes qui implosent
qui explosent pas avec la chaleur puis
c'est comme quand
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose s'appelle la vie
qui apparaît
la vie c'est au début c'est juste une
cellule une cellule qui bouge les se
évolue évolue au point qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle a il y a la
conscience qui existe puis on est
capable de
comprendre tout ça tout ce chemin-là que
c'est fait
pour qu'on arrive dans le trafic qu'on
soit en tabarnak parce que quelqu'un
répare notre tuyau
quelqu'un qui coupe sur l'autoroute et
que son groupe tu fais comme ok mais
vas-y peut-être moi je développe tout de
suite une pensée contraire à ce que
j'aurais dit longtemps s'il faut tout le
temps je me dise je me dis tout le temps
de choses sa femme accouche ou
c'est Mario
extraordinaire c'est le gars le plus fin
qui existe tout le temps c'est Mario il
dort quelque chose qui marche pas faut
qu'il aille mais dans le fond c'est très
bien que c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment qui est pas heureux dans sa vie
professionnelle qui a de rentrer à la
maison pour pas de bonnes raisons je
pense juste pour aller s'ouvrir une
bière s'écrase
mais bon et oui c'est pour dire que on
parle plus longtemps
mais merci
[Musique]
encore
c'est vraiment une belle galette une
belle galette entre les mains contents
et puis belle
comme ça c'est
[Rires]